about 10 miles south of brooklyn center
derrick shovin's defense attorneys are
working to counter dozens of prosecution
witnesses
who blame him for the death of george
floyd jamie yukis is following the trial
in minneapolis
any resister handcuffed or not should go
to the ground into a prone control
position
the defense's use of force expert barry
broad said chauvin was justified when he
handcuffed george floyd
face down on the pavement police
officers don't have to fight fair
they're allowed to overcome your
resistance by going up
a level the prosecution questioned
broad's judgment on cross-examination
what part of this is not compliant so i
see his arm position
in the picture that's posted right you
know a compliant person would have both
their hands in the small their back and
just be resting
comfortably versus like he's still
moving around
did you say resting comfortably i think
he came off terribly
minnesota criminal defense attorney joe
tamborino who is not affiliated with the
case
said broad's testimony lacked empathy he
said that that the police don't have to
fight fair
actually they do the jury wants to see
people on the stand who realize
the gravity of the situation regardless
of whether they find that the use of
force was
reasonable or unreasonable
trying to show that floyd was
susceptible to stress and drugs
the defense brought out body cam video
of a 2019
traffic stop in which floyd was arrested
the now retired police officer and a
retired paramedic
seen on this video testified floyd's
blood pressure was high
and he admitted to taking opioids that
day when we were
in the car for the first like eight
minutes we were talking
the defense also called shawanda hill to
testify
she was in the suv with floyd the day he
died and spoke about his physical state
when police arrived
he instantly grabbed the wheel and he
was like please please don't kill me
please please don't shoot me don't shoot
me where did i do
in total the defense called six
witnesses with the majority spending
less than 30 minutes on the stand
despite that whirlwind jurors were seen
taking lots of notes
medical experts are up next with still
no word on whether or not chauvin will
testify
anthony jamie thank you